♪ ♪ ♪
- Nous sommes au Cégep régional
de Lanaudière àololiette.
Ces étudiantes de première année
en soins infirmiers assisteront
particulière.
- Ma famille vient...
d'origine de Akwesasne.
des Premières Nations
à de futures infirmières
dans ce cégep qui se situe
où est morte Joyce Echaquan.
DIANE LABELLE, Cons scol. Prem.
Nations en éducation des adultes
et mes petits-enfants.
J'aimerais bien que
le monde change un peu pour
qu'il
aux nations autochtones.
- Cette conférence est
une initiative du Cégep.
ÉLIANE CHAPUT, prof. Cégep rég.
- J'aurais jamais pu avoir
le même impact qu'une personne
autochtone qui vient parler
de sa réalité. Des émotions,
ça, ils vont s'en rappeler.
- Diane parle de culture
mais aussi de la Loi sur
les Indiens, des pen
et des préjugés
- Le racisme systé
existe ici, au Québec.
Il devrait y avo
qui sont intégrés à l'intérieur
de toute for, , , , surtout
aux soins infirmiers.auauauauaun
spécifiq P P P Premières Nations
n'est obligatoire.
LUC MAet infirmiers du Québec
- C'est très inégal selon
les programmes de formation,
que ce soit dans les collèges
ou dans les universités.
auprès des établissementslllllle
en soins infirmiers, près
d'un cégep sur deux n'a aurerers
Nations, et ceux qui en ont
offrent moins de 5 heures.
- C'est d'interpeller
les maisons d'enser r r r r r rr
de leur formation des notions
de sécurisation culturelle.
- Il faudrait que ça soit
dans un deobobobobobobobobobobos
à mettre dans leur plan
des éléments relatifs
à la sécurisation culToute cetté
envers envers les ioioioioions
canadiennes, québécoise.
On les a colonis
un génocide. Après, il faut
recréer une co
- Le ministère de l'Enseignement
supérieur
la révision de la formation
colléginininininins infirmiers
et assure qu'il y intégrera
une
les Premières Nations.
ntntntntntnt, Diane continue
à livrer avec le même message.
d'utiliser ce que vous avez vécr
juste une partie de ça
- Pour tracer le cheminveveveven
entre nos peuples.
Comeau, Radio-Cieieieieieiette.